do you have any content creators outside
of other virtual youtubers or like
you know let's say 3d content yeah do
you watch any 3d youtubers that you
maybe one of they one day want to
collaborate in the future
oh gosh i do there's
you've had enough sims it's time to simp
yourself yeah who do you think i'm so
embarrassed
because there's really only one but i
feel like if i say
i don't know if we'd ever do a good
collab or if you'd even want to because
it's
it's a part of his personality that i
like a lot is that i don't
i don't know i don't know i feel like it
would be it would be odd but i've
just been a huge fan i'm a huge fan of
critical
oh do you know yes
the other day i let slip i accidentally
i we were i was playing minecraft with
gouda and
the other girls and gouda was leading me
into battle and i accidentally let out
like a quote
from him we were we were trying to taunt
the enemy and um
girl was like okay well if we taunt them
and we break down the bridge
then maybe that's how we get them and i
said hey [ __ ] boys
and i'm like i was like oh [ __ ]
immediately afterwards
he's probably gonna see it so critical
just saying pretty good
oh he's collaborated with project melody
charlie's like clearly a weeb right yeah
totally i mean he's he's like very
clearly a weep
i remember after we talked about jojo he
dm'd me and be like yo i'm ready i'm
ready to come on boys
[Music]
speaking of jojo's do you like jojo's i
have to ask
i've never seen it i'm sorry it's on my
list
it's on my list listen it's on my list
when i get some time
conor was just like you're my favorite
guest just kidding you're getting
awful guests you're in the top five
guests so far
listen i'm going to so i will say i
actually
i did watch a lot of your videos with uh
jojo's scenes
and um voice actors i'm honored
oh my god yeah it kind of made me want
to watch the show actually
wow we'll do it i will it's a promise
it's a promise
i'll do it i promise once again
this is just like trash taste is just
casually just like secretly it's just
like a cult to get people to just watch
everything goes back to jojo yeah
exactly we should uh we should get used
to do some voice acting
we should uh we should get you to do
that would be a fun video should we get
you to dub over some anime scenes
well i can give it my best shot all
right perfect damn free content for me
that's my idea no one's faking it no one
else why not because i've i've actually
wanted to like collaborate with you on
like the wrapping side of things
oh yeah sure like i definitely want to
like get more into that
because now that i'm because i've been
doing a lot this is how youtube is simp
by the way
yeah yeah yeah yeah we seem like
collaborating together nice
yeah that sounds about right i'm down
any time but unfortunately i
i have to say i'm not i'm not i'm no
good at freestyling
i mean oh no no i can't freestyle and
save my life well i'm pretty good
oh yeah no because legit like when i
like because when you
when i saw your tweet about how uh your
debut song hit like three million views
i think it was or four million views
yeah
some ridiculous amount of views and i
was just like i'm a try
let me let me try and get her attention
so i i just i just replied being like
hey we should spit on the side together
never thought i would get a reply and
then you were like hey yeah i'm down
yeah everyone was like collab oh my gosh
it's like immediately when you see two
youtubers like talk talk
on twitter they think like oh yeah
they're gonna there's gonna be a collab
two days later right like that's how it
works
i guess so huh wow it's just it's just
so funny where we could have like the
most minimal interaction yeah like
i'd like you could you could not even
talk to them you could see like some
just see you like like their tweet or
something
like that yeah people would be like yo
yo they're totally boning behind yeah
i feel like a lab coming oh yeah for
sure it's like wow
like can i just not casually interact
with someone on the offline without
having it be
related to business all of a sudden have
you had any awkward moments where you've
maybe like liked a tweet or followed
someone and then the viewers have been
like oh my god
why why oh for sure yeah i see i see
people's uh i see people's
messages or rather their conversations
all the time where they're talking about
uh
the the order in which i followed people
i think actually there was a
there was some discussion over the order
in which i followed uh the other
hololive girls
um they took note of that well they
thought there was like drama because of
that
not really drama but just people
assuming things like so it's drawing
their own conclusions right
yes like creating favoritism right yeah
yeah yeah exactly
yeah that kind of thing could you
imagine if that happened to like just
us like being like wow joey followed
connor before gone
that must mean that connor and joey are
like this and there's something between
jokes
the amount of conclusions that i jumped
to when it comes to our relationship
with other people it's like crazy
sometimes
over like the smallest details it's it's
the whole mentality of like i know your
life better than you know your wife
right it's like
all right dude yeah exactly you can say
all you want
people [ __ ] diagnosing i was the new
mental health disorder every episode
i feel like it's people are grasping at
straws because it's all that they have
right
they don't actually know any one of us
right so they take what
they take what they have and then they
they write these these stories because
it's all that they have to go off of
like detectives but as we all know it
doesn't really i'm sorry i
sipped my water really weird chat oh i'm
not chatting yeah sorry
about that i wanted to twitch right
there
can i get a feels bad man